this is jocko podcast number 252
with dave burke and me
jocko willink good evening dave good
evening echo charles
is taking care of some other business
on the last podcast number 251
with leif babin we started getting into
the book
guidelines for the leader and commander
by general
bruce clark but we only made it 13 pages
in two and a half hours and it's 117
page book
just to recap a little bit this is a
book that i searched for
for over a decade i originally heard
about this book in
my favorite book which is called about
face by colonel
david hackworth finally found a copy
a month and a half ago and so here we
are
just a little background once again on
general bruce clark
world war one world war ii korea
enlisted in 1917
ended up going to west point colonel in
world war ii then a general commanded
the fourth armored division
in patton's third army battled the bulge
distinguished service cross three silver
stars 45 years
of service
and then spent a bunch of time not only
leading troops but also training troops
or overseeing training commands so
awesome career hackworth talked about
him glowingly
in the book about face and that's where
that's where this start it took me a
long time to find this book
who did somebody texted me about it and
said it was the white whale
like you know this was that it was
definitely hard for me to find this book
but we have
it and that's it that's what we're gonna
do we're gonna go back into this book
so here we go back into guidelines for
the leader and commander
by bruce general bruce c clarke
so this section starts off with
administration some thoughts for the
commander
and he says in summation i would like to
point out
the close interrelationship between
training programs
and sound overall management
so this is something you know when
you're that young gung-ho leader
that just thinks hey we're here to
operate whatever that operation is
whether it's
shooting machine guns or whether that's
out selling things or making things
and you think hey i'm i'm on the front
lines i'm going to make things happen
and you think all the administrative
stuff you shouldn't have to worry about
that's not me and
and i know many individuals that are
like that
i know one individual in particular
that's like that whose name is jocko
because i was definitely like that many
commanders well i should say i was like
that when i was younger
because i absolutely i realized this and
you can hear you know
we'll talk about the paperwork drills
that we had to do and how
leif and seth came to me we shouldn't
have to do this stuff and i said oh
we're going to do it we're going to do
it better than anybody else
so i figured this out but it is a it is
definitely a learning
moment that people have and so why not
learn it right now
many commanders are defeated by poor
administration
imagine that just that statement many
commanders are defeated by
poor administration not defeated because
they were tactically unsound not
defeated because they made bad decisions
not defeated because they
couldn't come up with a good plan they
just failed because they're
administrative
losers
without sound administration a commander
cannot succeed in his training
and maintenance programs good
administration is nothing more
than applied common sense i'm including
here a number of items that may well be
considered a checklist
of indicators of sound administration
number one importance
of time the principal
coordinating device in the army is time
learn the proper time space factors so
you can be on time
and make reasonable demands of your
subordinates so
so that's number one by the way which is
probably why you hear a lot of talk
about
time management
just think about the idea that the first
thing he's going to say is time
this is someone who clearly understands
that of all the resources
in the world that we have that's the one
that matters the most because
we just can't produce more of that yeah
i was gonna say it's the it's the one
that matters the most and it's the
absolute one that we have the least
control you know how much control you
have time
you have zero you cannot stop it you
cannot bring it back you got to say have
the power curve
i hate that feeling i hate that feeling
and and let me tell you what i realized
this a while back
so when you go to the airport if you
show up to the airport late
and now look tsa doesn't care that
you're late
the baggage handler doesn't care that
you're late the uber driver does not
care what time your plane is leaving
they're they're doing what they're doing
and so what that does is it takes you
have no control
over that time once it started to
commence what do you have control
over going to the airport a little bit
earlier that's all that's all not that
big of a deal
go to the airport a little bit earlier
and you won't have to worry about tsa
you won't have to worry about baggage
you don't have to worry about
how long it takes for the uber driver or
the lift let's get proper
credit or lyft driver to show up and
bring you to the airport
not so so how do you get control you
can't control time
once it's unfolding you can't bring it
back you have to
you have to plan for it appropriately
and there's a
there's a sense of urgency and i don't i
have a pretty good sense of urgency and
you you may have
may or may not i know like at the muster
especially the earlier musters when we
weren't
when the backside wasn't quite the
well-oiled machine that it is now and it
certainly is a well-oiled machine now
the early musters it was not a
well-oiled machine so on the
on the front side people wouldn't know
that
when leif and i were walking out it's on
stage at 8 o'clock in the morning
we had two hours of sleep because we had
to do whatever
we had to do behind the scenes and
that's just the way it was
i can feel i can feel
when the shortage of time in fact i
think i feel the shortage of time
every single day every single waking
minute
there's a there's a thing that happened
at some point in my life and i don't i
don't know what
what when that was but i still think
about it now when you were just talking
about the feeling
what i thought you were going to talk
about is the feeling of when you feel
like you don't have enough time to do
something so being late or whatever or
i've got stuff i need to prepare for it
used to be that i used to feel there
wasn't enough time
and the feeling that makes me sick now
is that any time i'm behind which
happens i looking like man i'm behind i
didn't get enough done here i didn't
prep enough here
the feeling that bothers me the most is
looking back on the time that i
wasted the day before or the week before
when i thought
hey this is now i need to get ahead i
got a little window i got some white
space here which is actually
pretty rare and i look back on the time
that i wasted which is very different
than there isn't enough time
i honestly don't think i've ever felt
like i didn't have enough time
i always feel like i have wasted time
and that feeling of when i'm behind or
unprepared
man that drives me nuts as i look back
on what did i do yesterday or the day
before how did i
waste so much time knowing that i can't
get that back
and that's the feeling that bothers me i
think more than any other feeling is
i wasted my time yeah that's a that is a
doozy and this is
by the way item number one
item number one importance of time
next anticipate problems troublesome
incidents or situations can be avoided
if the probable consequences of existing
conditions are previously anticipated
incidents do not occur until the stage
has been set
for some time the outstanding officer
knows where things are likely to go
wrong and plans
preventive action
spend a little bit of time thinking of
through contingencies
and then come up with a plan and you
don't even have to come up with this
elaborate plan
you just have to know what you're gonna
do
in a broad sense
next personality of the commander
personality of the commander has an
enormous influence on his unit
in fact the unit may be said to be
nothing but an extension of the
commander's personality
it is essential that he makes his
presence felt by leaving his desk
to appear where work and training go on
and by talking to and knowing and
influencing his men
how many times did you see that in the
marine corps how about going for like
checking into a squadron
how much would the squadron reflect the
commander of the squadron completely
i mean that was the always the ultimate
difference because the thing about
squadrons it's probably true in a sealed
team
is that if you look at the squadrons
from the outside i was based at miramar
there were seven f-18 squadrons when i
was there
on paper they're all identical same
equipment
same number every metric that you would
measure it it's all the same there isn't
one squadron like that they get better
stuff
or better people they just get the same
thing that everybody else gets
and the only difference was obviously
the commander or the leader
and the squadrons would take on those
personalities
almost immediately when the new
commander take over
it's not it's it's crazy
it's crazy that's an extension of you
know the boat crew story and extreme
ownership hey we swap out we put in a
good leader into this
boat crew that's failing and all of a
sudden you've got this totally legit
boat crew that's winning and that
happens how many people are in a
squadron
200 200 people how many aircraft
12 12 aircraft 200 people and boom
you put a good leader in there but i
will say this though well you can
correct me if i'm wrong
but the marine corps
from my experience has a
tighter group a tighter
variance on their officers than
well then then certainly in the seal
teams
so in other words you might get in the
seal teams you might get
these outstanding officers and then
you'd get
some really good officers some solid
officers that kind of like the normal
you have some some really kick-ass guys
you have a bunch of normal guys and then
you have
the bottom group which would be pretty
outside the range so the range
would be pretty big it seemed to me like
the marine corps always had just tight
you know it's more controlled it's a
more controlled group it's a tighter
group
maybe maybe the high end
is not as often that you're gonna get
some just guy that's outside
the box of stellar look
maybe i don't know but i do know this
the chances of having
a marine corps platoon commander that
doesn't meet the grade
isn't is very low yeah and
and in the seal teams it would happen
more often because there's more slack
there's more room you're given more rope
to hang yourself
and you give guys rope and they can take
that rope and they can turn it into
something awesome or they can
they can hang themselves i always kind
of notice that
yeah i think that's right and you know
when you're inside that
the the disparity or that variance
becomes more evident to
you as you're inside that and you can
see that so there still is
a variance and when we looked at good
squadrons or bad squadrons however you
wanted to define that
a lot of times it was kind of just a
feeling almost
like an intangible quality of that's a
good squadron and that's a bad squadron
and the way we judge that was how
their people acted and you know how
other people acted
a reflection of their of their
leadership was exactly what he just said
and the squadrons would take on the
persona
and the person personality of their
leaders and the good leaders had good
squadrons and the bad leaders
or the the leaders that weren't as good
their squad just reflected that
so you got 12 aircraft and then are
those aircraft broken up into
sections or platoons somehow or is it
just every man for himself
no i mean they had 12 aircraft that in
theory were all the same you know they
weren't all flyable at a time but no we
didn't we wouldn't break them down
we would fly an element sometimes a two
or a four ship but the aircraft were
just
rotated through so you could be in any
given aircraft on any day
so in a sealed platoon you could have
a a great officer
and you could have a great platoon you
could also have a great platoon chief
or a great leading petty officer or
assistant platoon commander chances are
you're not going to get a pipe hitting
the system so you can get some really
solid guys but they just don't have the
experience
so basically what you needed was ah
singular really good leader didn't
necessarily need to be the top guy
but somebody you know at a sealed team
you might have a great
seal team commanding officer you also
might have and that could
really make the whole seal team great
you could also have a great
seal team command master chief who's a
kick-ass guy
you could have a great seal uh ops
master chief
so you as long as you had one of these
guys
in the team that was legit
badass you could you're gonna pull it
off
unless you get somebody that's an idiot
in there too if you get somebody with a
big ego you know the
the the the command master chief has a
big eagle or the commanding officer has
a big e and all of a sudden you got
conflict
then you you know all bets are off and
we got mayhem
but chances are if you got one good
leader you're gonna you're gonna
the the group will take on the
personality the commander
so if you don't like the personality of
your team guess what
go look in the mirror next counseling of
individuals
at the company level the commander and
the chaplain are the ones
to whom the men will come for guidance
when they have to
when they have or think they have
problems most commanders are usually
surprised
number of men who actually have real
personal difficulties
these may take a variety of forms money
troubles
family difficulties disciplinary
problems character weaknesses and
spiritual conflicts the commander's
problem is twofold
first he must train himself to recognize
and to look for the early signs that
identify a man with
problems early recognition of a problem
like
timely diagnosis of a disease makes the
treatment
and cure easier second
having identified the problem the
commander must take the proper
steps to correct it often his own
counseling
will have to be sufficient but in other
cases he'll have to call on others
for help here it is essential that the
correct source be used that the man
whose pay record is incorrect shouldn't
be sent to the chaplain
but to the finance clerk all right so
we're we're we're making sure that we
identify problems
we have to look for that this has always
been a problem for me because no one
ever tells me
anything when something's going wrong no
one wants to tell me
that they're overworked or they're they
don't want to do another operation or
whatever no one ever wants to tell me
that
so i i have to drag it out of people i
have to have intel sources that will
tell me that the troops are getting
tired or
the guys are worn out or whatever
recognition of outstanding work this is
the next section
a sure way to instill loyalty is to
recognize outstanding work from your
subordinates
satisfaction in a job well done as a
trait of
all men and recognition
by others of the same good work will
appeal to the vanity that lies in all of
us
another thing i'm bad at i'm horrible at
recognizing people for good work
i just think everyone's doing what they
should be doing
and it's very seldom that i
take the time to like thank somebody i
usually have to think about it i'm
horrible at that
uh leif has told me though that when i
would say something that someone did
good
they'd be super stoked that every girl
would be fired up
recognition can take many forms
decorations letters accommodation oral
acknowledgement at a formation or the
issuance of a three-day pass but
whatever the form is essential
that the commander is a for that the
commander be alert to outstanding
performance and give timely public
recognition
when it is due can i just kind of what
about just a simple head nod
does that work yeah that can work man i
mean part of that is you got to pay
attention to what
matters to your people yeah and you know
the thing that i always craved the most
the recognition i didn't
the recognition i wanted was to be left
alone and if my leadership
didn't when my leadership wasn't
micromanaging me and giving me the
flexibility that that was him okay i
must be doing something right
cool we're good but there's nothing
wrong with recognition i'm not trying to
pile on the idea of like don't
acknowledge your people's good work
but what it matters to somebody doesn't
always matter to everybody and you gotta
actually pay attention what matters and
over time
the the head nod and keep doing what
you're doing
dude that's good to go yeah you know i i
had trouble with this
because and i still do because
you know when you're the boss
right well in my mind i
you know if i say hey dave good job i
just i think you don't care about that
because i'm just some other guy that's
trying to work hard and whatever
and i i remember i've told the story
before i was
first got to ramadi needed a certain
type of laptop computer for my office
and the radio guy the it guy the radio
man guy who's a great dude
i told him hey i need to have i need to
have a sipper and a nipper laptop side
by side and he's like hey we don't
really have enough
nipper these are i needed a classified
computer and an unclassified computer
side by side so that when i was working
i could
if i needed some information that was
from the unclassified side i could look
it up
if and and then continue to work on
whatever i was working on
so i remember i said hey
i i called him into the tackle operation
center and i said hey i want a
classified computer here and an
unclassified computer here and he goes
well we don't really have enough
unclassified computers
and i kind of went oh okay and then a
few minutes later i
walked through the the chow hall and we
had set up this
unclassified computer station with six
computers
for everyone to use now everyone had
computers in their tent too
this wasn't like you know everyone was
lined up to use these
six computers no it was just somebody
decided hey we'll put some internet
computers out here
and so i walked out i said wait a second
we have all these unclassified computers
right here
and i went back and said hey man those
computers that are out there give one to
me and he was like oh roger that
and i realized oh i need to make the
call on that and
what i say has impact you know
and so when you say something negative
it has a big impact because you know
sometimes
that that plan doesn't make any sense
and everyone just beats will be quiet
because they they think that you don't
like the plan when reality is you're
just thinking uh
maybe i could maybe come up with a
different plan so you got
overall and i wrote about this in
leadership strategy and tactics your
words
have power and impact so remembering
that when you give someone some
compliments it may have some
it has more significance than you might
think
efficiency reports i was i was thinking
myself when i saw this i was like
you know i'll kind of skip over this who
cares you know no one wants to hear
about efficiency reports
then i read it and i said oh i will
absolutely include this
with the advent of enlisted efficient
efficiency reports
the command so efficiency reports so for
in the civilian sector what this would
boil down to as you know an evaluation
it's a performance evaluation for
someone
the commander now has a new tool which
will assist him in gaining the desired
motivation from his key enlisted
personnel
too often the efficiency report becomes
the padlock
on the barn door after the horse has
been stolen
what a great way to think about wasting
uh some kind of evaluation format
performance evaluation
hey dave you went and did something for
a year you did your job and then you
show up
after a year and i say yeah you didn't
do that great of a job
what good is that the barnard the horse
already got stolen
i have found that unacceptable
performance and the resultant
bad efficiency reports can often be
reduced to a minimum
through early effective observation and
counseling
gee what a novel idea when dave starts
screwing up
don't wait six months to give him an
efficiency report say
hey dave it's been three weeks you've
been on this project i already see that
you're heading the wrong direction
let's talk if a commander makes it a
practice to observe his men closely and
call them in in periodically
for an evaluation of their performance
in terms of strengths and weaknesses
he can often correct deficiencies
without it becoming necessary
to issue an unsatisfactory efficiency
report
boom it's a tool that you've got that
you can use
a three-part program of and here's the
three parts
observation and evaluation counseling
and guidance of the individual
individual and then further observation
to determine the response to the
counseling is your key to effective use
of the efficiency report
then it becomes a tool for improvement
rather than merely a reward or
punishment for past performance
wow wow imagine that
and it's unsapped because in the navy
you get an evaluation or a fitness
report
once a year yeah and there's a lot of
companies that we work with that do
something similar
there's that's just not often it's not
often enough
it's not even close and those periodic
evaluations they actually don't even
need to be that formal it's
really just the core of building
relationships is getting to know your
people by being out with them
the best thing you can do is know your
people well enough to be able to
recognize
when they're going in the wrong
direction and if you talk to your people
once a year
you're not going to know that because
you don't even know what they're
typically like
and so if i'm working with you and i
know jocko pretty well and all of a
sudden jaco shows up one day and he's
not jocko i can get involved right then
but the only way for me to tell that
you're not yourself or not
doing the things that i'm used to is i
gotta be around you just a little bit
more and
you don't need to track all the stuff
every single time you don't need to know
the formal piece of it formal counseling
is important
but the best tool you've got is actually
know them well enough to go
something's not right and if you can
intercept that on day one
rather than day 30 or 60 or 90
not only do you actually help solve that
problem that other person
recognizes that you know and care about
them enough to get involved and
being able to do that is really a
function of your time more than anything
else
of being around your people to know them
well enough to identify that
when they're off the path so it comes
down to time management
uh i when i talk about planning and i
say okay if i give dave
a mission to asking and say okay dave
come up with a plan on how you want to
do this
if i leave for 12 hours and you were
three degrees off in your what you
thought you should do versus what i
thought you should do
i come back 12 hours there's 12 hours of
wasted time because you've been going on
the
wrong direction and now you're way off
course if i go hey dave
here's here's the mission you need to
execute here's the task
come up with you know some con ops i'll
be back in a half an hour
you're three degrees off it oh it barely
even takes a nudge to get you right back
on track and we're we're tracking
so the earlier you give people
correction corrective measures
the the the minimum the the
limit of what you have to do to get them
back on course
is is totally limited it's the minimum
workforce required
so if you and i if i said hey dave
here's a mission tasking
come up with how you want to do i'll be
back in half an hour when i came back in
a half an hour and you're three degrees
off course
i barely i probably would be able to get
you back on course
by asking you a ques not even telling
you anything just by saying
hey what do you think about what do you
think about this area up to the north do
you think that's a do you think there
could be enemy up there
that's kind of what the intel says right
and you'd say yeah and i'd say oh
are you gonna put a blocking force up
there you didn't have a blocking force
in your plan you go yes absolutely and
cool now we're totally
square yeah if i walked away for 12
hours and let you come up with a plan
you're wide open to the enemy attack
from the north you have
you used your blocking forth and force
in a totally different area you don't
even have enough people now because you
so it's just it's totally wrong and now
we've got to come in with blunt force
trauma
and now it's not your plan anymore
you've given up ownership it's just it's
just a nightmare it's crazy
so the earlier i get involved the less
force i have to
use and my goal as a leader is to use
the minimum force required
and the longer i wait to use force the
worse it's going to be
and if you're out there thinking about
the time the the daunting
task of spending all that time up front
the roi on your investment of time
upfront is
is it's it's unlimited because
if you make that investment upfront
which seems like a lot of time what you
save on the back end of that so from the
time manage at standpoint yeah
yes it is an additional investment of a
little bit of time up front it is and
you gotta account for that time that is
not free time
but what you save from that
roi all day all day it's not even close
and you know what's
funny is you you're i i disagree with
you because you say it's this big
investment up front it's nice
no investment up front it's me going hey
dave how are you going to execute this
and you go i'm going to do it like this
and i go oh don't forget there's enemy
up there yeah i'm going to put a
blocking force
okay cool there we go that's how that
was that took 18 seconds
the story we tell ourselves like hey i
can't come back in 30 minutes because
yeah you actually can you're absolutely
right and it's the idea of
whatever it seems like i don't have time
a you do have time
and if you do need to do some mental
calculation of that time the roi in that
time
is well worth whatever you might miss
for that five minute check-in
that happens up front and it also shows
another person
oh jaco cares jacques was in the game
jaco's paying attention
i wonder if that means i'm going to be
more or less interested
in giving you a really good plan if i
know you care about it
you know what's interesting too roi
the roi on time is the
it's it doesn't even make sense and i'll
tell you why
because i don't get that time back if
you're supposed to execute a mission
tonight
and i give you 12 hours to plan and i go
hey here's the mission you got to
execute
and i don't come back and check in by
the time 12 hours go by and i realize
that your plan is a total disaster
it's not that the roi it's not i don't
get return on my investment it's that we
it's the
it's it's bankruptcy it's total failure
it's total and complete failure i can't
even get it back the roi
is negative it's it's horrible whereas a
little investment up front
total game changer totally now here's
another section i wasn't going to read
and i remember i i sent you a picture of
this book
or sections of the book and you you said
just read the whole
just you're gonna just cover the whole
thing yeah and i was kind of like yeah
you know that's cool i'm sure i'll cover
a lot of it
but you know i'm always i don't want to
waste people's time so i'm looking for
okay what can we streamline a little bit
so there was a section called promotion
and look if you're in the civilian world
how much do you care about how they
advance people in the army
in 1952 right whatever
and then i read it a little bit i go
okay well looks like we're covering this
too
and i'll tell you how in a second so it
says promotion the promotion policy of a
commander's
of a command has a strong bearing on
morale and overall efficiency
it must be fair and by the way
this is one thing that you're going to
start to pick up in this section of the
book and in some of the other sections
there is absolutely part of general
clark that is looking to get promoted
and he you can feel it and there's going
to be other places where you feel it and
what's
cool is you'll feel it and he'll say it
and then a little later on he'll he'll
hint that
you know what that doesn't really even
matter so we're gonna go back and forth
we're gonna come up against some of
these things
where you say okay he
he's a he's a guy that really cares
that's in the game just to get promoted
right which i am not a big proponent of
hey your main reason to be in the game
is get promoted that being said
if i have got a team and i want to take
care of my team
well how do i how do i do the best job
taking my care of my team i get promoted
so i have more leverage and more power
and i can
be positive influence on even more
people so
getting promoted if you're getting
promoted for yourself
we don't like that and by the way when i
say we
i'm talking about the people that work
for you if you're getting promoted for
yourself
they don't like it we don't like that
but if you're getting promoted so that
you can
help the team achieve their mission
protect the team take care of the team
grow the team
influence the team in a positive way if
that's why you're getting pro promoted
cool good on you good we we like that
you're doing it for the right reasons
and if you think
if you think if you think you can sneak
around and get promoted for yourself but
you don't really beat it i'm
promising you i promise you everybody
sees it
so promotion it must be fair buy it the
commander can encourage men to develop
themselves for permissions
for positions of supervision and
leadership
the commander should consider the
following qualifications and
attributes when considering a man for
promotion so he goes into a list
and what i did and what i wrote down
here was
when i go through this list aim the aim
this list at yourself
you aim this list at yourself are you
promotable number one reliability
number one reliability number one
reliability
when
when when i talk about relationships i
use the word relationships i'm really
talking about trust
and trust if you don't have
trust inside of a team all is lost
well yeah so the question is how do you
build trust
well let me give you a good hint the
number one clue right here
be reliable be reliable okay so that's
number one number two
his knowledge of his present job and his
preparation for the next higher one
so be knowledgeable proficiency text
test scores leadership can he direct men
ability to organize and manage a job
again these are all things if you aim
these things at yourself
it is a powerful thing to think about
knowledge to detect and courage to
correct
errors in subordinates
initiative does he perform well without
close supervision
appearance military courtesy and
neatness
this makes me happy that i wrote the
warrior kid books
[Laughter]
maintenance of equipment individual and
organizational attitude
loyalty enthusiasm ability
as an instructor ability as an
instructor
and i'll tell you where i've been
thinking about that there's a couple
other things that we'll clue in on this
we've been talking we've been developing
leadership certification program at
echelon front and one of the things that
we've been
dancing around is the fact that
there's there's
maybe well we were dancing around with
like two different pipelines like you're
either a trainer that's going to train
people how to lead or you're a leader
and you're in a supervisory position and
you're a management position and you're
a leader
and then we've kind of gotten to a point
where we say listen these are the same
thing and in order to become
a good leader you have to be able to
teach you have to be able to show people
how to do things
so it's interesting that he's got
ability as an instructor
because listen if i'm going to promote
you dave from
you know from being in charge of a squad
to being in charge of a platoon i want
you to be able to teach i want you to be
able to instruct
that is absolutely important and and in
a
in a leadership environment i want you
to be able to teach the team about
leadership i want you to
be able to teach when i put you in
charge of platoon i want you to be able
to teach
your squad leaders how to lead i want
you to be able to teach your fire team
leaders how to lead
and i also want you to be able to teach
them how to break down
a 240 golf right i want you to be able
to teach those things so the ability to
be an instructor
is important and it's equally important
because when we teach
we learn yeah that that second point was
what i was
was thinking in my head a lot is you
know top gun
for my community is kind of the apex of
instruction you know the quality of
instruction is
is kind of at its peak there because
you get to focus just on that you don't
have all these other distractions going
on so you focus on that
i learned more there than i did anywhere
else
and the ability to teach is really comes
from
how much you truly understand something
and for me being able to fly an airplane
or run the radar or manage the systems
a lot of people can do that but if
when you try to teach something it
exposes your
gaps in knowledge and a good teacher
when they break down
what they're going to teach they
recognize oh i don't actually understand
this very well
so before i teach it to you i got to go
learn about this more
so the learning connected to the
teaching i learned more
because the my obligation was to teach
it and as i'm learning to teach
exposed all the things i didn't know so
a good teacher actually has to
understand it better than anybody else
and that connection between those two is
so critical and
the idea of teaching is i think a
reflection or anything of
how well you truly know something and
you don't really test yourself on how
well you know it until you have to
explain it to somebody else
yeah right as you started i just wrote
down you know i hope he's about to say
that as you teach you learn and that's
exactly what you said
you identify the gaps in your own
knowledge and you go okay i better
figure this out
i better go run this drill i better pull
the thread on that until i understand it
better
next participation in unit and community
activities
does he use his time off to improve
himself
aim that one at yourself
is he a good soldier all the time
is the job he is charged with being done
better now than it was when he took over
judgment and common sense a good scale
of values
ability to receive and carry out
instructions
has he been efficiently filling his
grade position
accident record incident record a wall
in article 15 which means has the dude
gotten in trouble before
really powerful list there may be other
considerations
they should add up to confidence that
the man will play his part well
under any conditions especially in
unusual situations
what's interesting about that why why
does that make me
like think awesome thoughts
because what that says is that this
military guy
who believes in discipline and believes
in being able to do your job
and and being able to receive and carry
out instructions
that's what he said but he wants you to
be especially
able to perform in unusual situations
well how
how how do you get good at performing in
all useless unusual situations
you get tested you get tasked you get
things thrown at you
and you have to use your mind it's great
that you can you have the ability to
receive and carry out instructions
this is my point it's great that you
have the ability to receive and carry
out instructions that's great
but if i throw something unusual at you
and what you have to do is figure it out
and you don't know how to do that
we got a problem
unless you want him as a member of your
team do not promote him or recommend him
for a promotion
the promotion policy of a unit commander
should be published and understood by
all
and then it goes into this next section
elimination of ineffective personnel
dichotomy leadership when to hire one to
fire when a mentor when to fire
it is the commander's duty to contribute
to raising the standards of the united
states army
what a beast statement that is it is the
commander's duty to contribute to
raising the standards of the united
states army
one approach to this goal is a
continuous evaluation of his personnel
officers non-commissioned officers and
enlisted men alike
when ineptness is revealed or continuing
ineffectiveness is detected
in officers and non-commissioned
officers it is the commander's duty
to see that corrective measures are
taken
elimination or reduction in grade as
appropriate so you've done your
escalation of counseling
i've done everything i can to see if i
can straighten dave burke out
he can't make it happen dave burke needs
to go bye-bye
the importance of a good but fair
reduction policy
is often overlooked few things disrupt a
unit more than the presence of
inefficient leaders
gee that comes as a big shock right few
things disrupt the unit more than the
presence of inefficient leaders so let's
think about this
if dave's working for me and dave is
inefficient and dave doesn't do a good
job
and dave drops the ball and dave's
working for me and i continue to allow
dave to be there
what does the team think of me yeah what
does it say about you as a leader it
says
i suck as a leader that's what it says
or it says that you you don't actually
care because
this leader this dave that's
underperforming who is he actually
affecting he's affecting the whole team
and you know a synonym for that
reduction in rank is
that's rank is essentially
responsibility so as your rank grows in
the military your responsibility grows
so you don't have to have a ranking
structure in your organization
you've got responsibility for you know
this guy's a team leader or supervisor
or impacts a team
this guy's underperformance that you
tolerate doesn't just affect this
underperformer it's
all the people in his influence and
they're looking at you saying
this is what jocko is going to put up
with this is the bar that he's going to
tolerate and oh by the way
this affects me personally and just
like on the other extreme of getting rid
of people way too
soon way too prematurely that you
haven't invested in keeping the wrong
people around
in terms of what that does to your
leadership capital
regulations provide for the reduction of
enlisted men and the separation of
officers for
inefficiency and actual performance of
their job or as a result of misconduct
the latter is where where we fall most
often
we fail or sorry the ladders we fail
most often
we fail because we do not face up to the
fact
that key personnel to be good leaders of
young men
must also have good character
poor character will inevitably manifest
itself
in poor conduct leaders influence the
actions of their subordinates
most leaders are considered by those of
less rank as highly qualified
and competent therefore when poor
conduct is manifested off duty by anyone
in leadership capacity
it has a detrimental effect on the
entire unit
especially dangerous in this regard are
those key personnel
who are outstanding in their work
for their influence is even greater on
troops who
observing them will often emulate their
actions even to the point of delinquency
if this condition persists it can lead
to a broken
breakdown of discipline throughout the
unit in an incredibly
short time leaders with character
deficiencies
regardless of how good they might appear
in field training
are a luxury we cannot afford
what'd you write down i wrote down
character
and conduct
what all i was thinking as you're
reading this
you you cannot and i learned this in the
marine corps you cannot separate
your work life from some other part of
your life
if you were a leader you are a commit
you are committed to being a leader
all the time and where you are
scrutinized
the most where there's most risk is how
you act
off the clock if you want to call it
that so i could stand up in front of my
my marines and tell them all the things
i expect from them
whatever those might be i could make a
list they're all good and i could behave
like that at work
if i go out in town or back in my
personal life or anywhere else outside
of work
and i reveal that i don't live by the
expectations i set for my people my
character is revealed that i don't
actually apply those to myself
the degree to which that undermines me
as a leader at work is actually
much worse than if i just wasn't great
at work and i'm just working on it and
trying to get better
and your character your character sooner
or later
is gonna be revealed because you're
going to find yourself in a place where
you think nobody's looking or you're
going to find yourself in an environment
where you think
it's okay and who you are is going to
come out
and he made he said i wish i wrote
exactly this your character will be
connected to your conduct
so who you really are eventually is
going to influence
how you behave and if your plan is to
put on a good front at work
you're going to get found out and the
damage to that your credibility and the
damage to the team
if that's that you just you simply
cannot separate
who you are as a leader and have a
period of time or a place where you
don't have to hold yourself to that same
standard
yeah the that's what i was that's what i
wrote down when you were talking
was hey you can try and put up that
front well you already said if what you
try and put out that front you
if you in your mind and your little tiny
brain because it is tiny if this is what
you think you have a small brain
if in your brain your tiny little brain
you think it doesn't really matter no
one will notice
your brain is small and you are stupid
because everybody sees that
everybody and everybody is watching you
all
the time they're watching it they see
you all the time
crazy uh re-enlistment while the
commander should place heavy emphasis on
re-enlistment and do all in his power to
retain effective personnel he should
bear in mind
that the army wants quality not quantity
make your program selective
social life every army post should be
close-knit happy family commanders can
foster this by ensuring that families of
their men
have adequate social life a particular
importance
is the inclusion of youth activities
designed especially for youth and not
for adults
good programs in this field will not
just happen they will require your best
people
you know when you start looking at
building
what you just said you know what how do
you expect
the people to act if you haven't given
them a good support structure
with their family just doesn't work it
is essential that all recommendations he
talks about this non-commissioned
officers advisory council which is hey
you've gotta you gotta
you can assemble groups of your workers
of your team of your employees the
leaders the frontline troops you can
assemble groups of them
and get feedback from them
and he says it's essential that all
recommendations receive the attention of
the major commander concerned
for failure to act on justified
recommendations will defeat the whole
purpose of having these councils
and you know it's interesting we've been
doing some work at echelon front with
some of these councils which is always
cool because now you're getting
people from different
different cross-sections of a company
that are sort of
these councils and that's been
interesting it's been very interesting
and it's kind of what we do anyways
when we go into a company we
you know we get a cross-section but it's
nice when the companies already have a
cross-section that we are talking to
so if you're running a company right now
or if you're in a company right now
it's a good idea to think about putting
together some kind of a council where
you say hey
we need to take the best ideas take the
best practices take the grievances that
we have
assemble them together in a logical way
to push them up the chain of command
because if the
if the boss you know has us working late
every friday
and the boss doesn't know how much that
negatively impacts us how can we expect
him to change it
answer we cannot get together
put forth information in a consolidated
effort
so that the boss knows what's happening
and if you're the boss and you get that
feedback
implement as best you can act on it yeah
direction of staff so staff is no more
than an extension of the commander's
abilities and a good commander must be
able to handle the staff property
officers of a staff should carry out the
commander's policies enthusiastically
by the same token should bring to the
attention of the commander those matters
deserving his personal attention
staff visits to make sound decisions the
commander must
receive timely and reliable reports from
his staff which means
that his staff must visit unit
activities
so talk to us dave about
what they're talking about when they say
staff
so the command like when i was a
commander of a unit my staff i had
um i had subordinate leaders that were
responsible for
for different elements so i'd have like
an operations staff that ran the
operations i have a maintenance app that
ran
the maintenance and logistics and supply
and all all the different components and
out underneath these leaders
which were really staff officers kind of
building the plans were a whole bunch of
people implementing
their processes or their or their sops
or whatever they had created
if you got a staff officer someone
working for you that has a plan
and has their team implementing the plan
out in the field or out on the flight
line
and they don't go out there to see how
effective it is what the real barriers
are what the problems are and they are
sort of operating in that vacuum of
their their staff position or in their
their cubicle their office
and they're not out there with those
people they have no sense of
the real feedback of the problems and
the challenges are people facing
while they're implementing their plans
and so
it comes i think it's as simple as what
you described i think he said it like in
the first pages
leave your office and go out and spend
time with your people to see what's
really going on down there but what if
seven years ago i had that job and i
kind of remember what it was like back
then
is that good does that does that cover
me
[Laughter]
no the um
it also is just the connection to having
your people see that you're willing to
go out there and just spend time with
them
the benefit of spending time with your
people on one sense it's actually really
important
and we can talk about all the different
things that i would learn when i just
spent time with my people i learned
about things i learned how things worked
i learned the challenges they had
but there is about there is some level
of effort that it takes for you to get
away from your desk as a leader
to go spend time with your people and i
and most of the time your troops
actually understand that they know it's
not as simple for this
for the ceo to just get away so when you
do the power of
of of you doing that on is is really
significant they recognize that you're
making the effort to do it
now if your plan is to do we call these
touch and goes had go out there and like
show your face to the team if that's
your kind of like hey i'm gonna
show my face and you don't actually get
out spend time with them they're gonna
see that coming a mile away
but if you just spend a little time what
you'll end up getting is
a bunch of unfiltered feedback that
didn't run through the chain and get
chopped by all your staff all the way up
to you
you get unfiltered sterilized totally
you know what what you want more than
anything you want a 19 year old lance
corporal
who's turning a wrench on a jet to
explain to you why this is hard
now of course you want to use the chain
command i want that to run through the
chain i want to see that multiple
ways but if you want unfiltered feedback
to what's really going on with your team
you have to get down to spend time with
your team
that being said back to the book it is
essential however that a staff
officer making such visits understands
the thin line that divides
staff supervision from meddlesome
interference so there's the dichotomy of
leadership don't be jumping the chain
he must realize that he is not a
commander
should avoid criticizing subordinate
commanders
and report and said their shortcomings
to his commander
and should he see that his reports
reflect favorably as well as unfavorable
conditions
so you've got to make sure that you're
not just being a rat going out there
yeah
and you've got to make sure that you
don't interfere
right it can cause interference you know
some if if
dave you're having a a meeting at
echelon front and you've got all the
instructors because you want to cover
some
ldap information and you're doing a zoom
meeting
and you're going to talk shop about a
bunch of different things and all of a
sudden i just pop in there
well you know what am i doing in there
and you had an agenda and all of a
sudden i'm in there like there's times
where
i'm just causing interference and
that's really not what we're looking to
do
now all that being said oh go ahead i
was just going to say
especially as i got more senior when i
was in charge of an entire squadron
my bias was actually towards trying
to spend time and my bias was towards
normalizing
their view of me as a person and let me
just explain that for a minute
every single person in the squadron knew
who the squadron commander was
everybody from the next the next in
command to me my number two guy all the
way down to the
my most junior marine and the if i did
nothing the natural state with them
would be for them to put a almost put me
in a pedestal
that they couldn't even relate to me as
a person along with that
i really didn't have a lot of time i was
busy doing a lot of things especially
dealing with higher headquarters and
other components so i didn't have
all day every day so the times that i
was out there was rare because
i simply had a lot going on so my bias
and i'm talking the needle a little bit
off-center my bias was
if i could spend a little more time
instead of a little less time if i could
get a little more understanding what's
going on
then a little less that's that was my
bias
because the natural tendency for most
people would
almost put a commander on a pedestal
that's not even a person
he's he's he's elevated to a status that
it's almost unrelatable
and if i could create just a little bit
of thawing of hey i'm a normal person i
really want to know what's going on down
here i really want to have some
connection on what you're doing
i would bias towards that there were so
many other forces at play there was
very little risk of me being the type of
guy that i'm just hanging i hate what's
going on down here
how's your boss and what so the risk of
there was lower
your point i think that point is totally
valid and the reason i'm making mention
of this is that
at least in the military the chain of
command is is understood
and the barrier for me was that being so
rigid
that people didn't see me as a person
who really wanted to know what's going
on
so i would bias in that in that
direction as a if i was splitting the
difference in what i was going to do i
would try to spend more time than less
if you're not seen as a human being you
don't have connections with the troops
if you don't have any connections with
the troops
n none of this none nothing that we're
talking about even matters in any way
shape or form basically
basically just you've got to be a person
yeah
the question of visitors back to the
book a commander can expect
many inspectors and visitors and it
should be his policy to encourage and
welcome visits and import from important
officials
this of course means that his house must
be constantly kept in order
that is how it should be for the unit
that is uniformly
excellent in all things at all times is
one that will be outstanding in battle
look upon visitors not as interruptions
or harassment
but as the chance to show the public
just
how really good your unit is that's
that's pretty epic
dude that is so important and
i keep coming back to my time as a
squadron commander because when i
commanded a unit it was the very first
operational f-35 b squadron in the world
it was
the focal point of all things marine
aviation it was a
under a microscope and we had visitors
all the time everything from like us
senators
four-star generals local congressmen
everybody wanted there's a massive
investment in time and they wanted to
know what's going on
and there's a there's a propensity
towards when we get
no hey you're getting a notification
you're getting this delegation's coming
to visit
was what they would focus their time on
is preparing for that visit
and i i wanted no time
spent on preparation for the visit we're
not gonna clean the floors
we're not gonna we are gonna operate as
normal i want them to come down and see
what and if you actually are that
squared away unit
you don't need to prepare for those
visits and if your plan is oh they're
coming hey everybody started
clean up shining your boots and emptying
trash cans and cleaning the tops of
doors that you things you would not
normally do
my view on visits was they can show up
any place
anytime anywhere with no notice i don't
care and if i'm not there
no factor somebody will cover down staff
sergeant will cover down
lieutenant i don't care and the message
that sent to the marines was two folders
one is
hey the boss doesn't freak out when
people come to visit it's no big deal
and
if we're actually as squared away as we
think we are who cares show up come
check it out
you're going to see what you're going to
see is the best squadron in the world
that's what you're going to see
so no factor visits are not a big deal
check unit athletic programs athletic
programs developed in conjunction with
the physical fitness program will do
much to enhance the physical stamina of
unit
why why do i cover this why do i even
cover this
well because it's true well because
if we're out there so focused on
leadership that we
don't we let our physical bodies fall
apart
we're wrong and he knows that
an act an active interest in athletics
is provided by the commander through
proper motivation and personal
interest a well-planned and
integrated athletic program is an
important part of any units training
program it will
take the minds of the men off off what
some of them consider
as the monotony of training help keep
the command in better physical shape
help build a unit esprit de corps help
develop
self-discipline and team spirit
ah man we get away from that
emphasis in athletic programs should be
on the small
unit level such as company battery troop
rather than at higher levels
so look i don't know what situation
you're in in life or what your business
is doing
but doing something physical together is
very
very helpful
anybody that's ever done an ftx with
echelon front knows exactly
what you're talking about yeah even
coming to the muster you know come to
the muster
and come do pt at the muster and you're
doing something that's hard but it's fun
and we're having a good time
we're doing them oh by the way we're
doing the muster
december 4th and 5th so no december 3rd
and 4th
in texas and we're still going to do pt
we've not quite figured out what we're
going to do instead of jiu jitsu on
on the closing night but we're going to
figure something awesome out
but why why do we do that because
people feel better it brings the look
people have
will have a thousand people there well
for the muster in
in the next semester we won't have a
thousand people there we'll probably
have
a third of that or maybe half that but
people from all over the country will
get together they've never met before
and they will bond
in 45 minutes of early morning pt
if you get up at five in the morning and
pt you'll be less tired
than if you got up at seven in the
morning and went straight to the
conference room you'll be less tired
stopped at the donut factory
so he talks about attractive living
areas you know providing people a good
place to live well that applies with
plan
supplying people a good place to work
maintenance and supply economy you'll
recall that on the subject of training
habits i said that men will do in combat
what they
have been taught in and practice in
training this is equally true
in the area of maintenance for in combat
high maintenance standards
become a matter of life and death of
equal significance
is supply supply economy that wasted
bullet
or gallon of gas may seem insignificant
now
but what a difference it may make when
the chips are down
exclamation point i think that's the
only exclamation point he uses in this
book
train how you fight and if you're
allowed to be
sloppy or cut corners and not do the
maintenance where you're gonna end up
you're gonna end up in a bad way
good leadership on the company level can
only thrive in a climate of good
commandership
on the battalion level and above
what company commanders have a right to
expect from
commanders above
so so here look if you're working if
you're a boss this is what you should be
providing
to the people below you that their
honest errors be pointed out
but be underwritten at least once in the
interest of developing initiative and
leadership
boom what does that mean it means if
someone makes a mistake
one time you don't drop the hammer on
them you
you show them support that they had
initiative
that they showed good leadership so
that's what we're supposed to point them
out
hey dave bad initiative or good
initiative bad judgment
you know i i like that you took action
but
let's think through the action that you
took that's fine
to be responsible for and be allowed to
develop their own
units with only essential
guidance from above
you are responsible for developing
however you want to do it dave you got
your team
however you want to develop that team
here's here's here's the minimum
requirements and this is the mission
only the essential guidelines yeah what
do we say we say minimum force required
we want to lead with the minimum force
required
a helpful attitude toward their problems
loyalty down as well as up
that they not be subjected to the
needling of unproductive statistics
competitions between like units
just harassing people the best in
commandership
that their that the needs of their units
be anticipated
and provided for that's not too much to
ask
that i anticipate that dave's going to
need more bullets or more ammunition or
more
fuel and i have it for them
to be kept oriented as to the mission
and situation
of the unit above a well thought out
program of training work and recreation
good training
and work management to receive timely
clear-cut and positive orders and
decisions which are not constantly
changed
that the integrity of their tactical
units be maintained
in assigning essential tasks that's so
smart
that was a little trick that i did i
would keep my little fire teams together
keep the squads together as much as i
could to keep the platoons together as
much as i could look we were
interoperable
but if you can keep a fire team together
they are so good to go
yeah you want them tight
you i think a couple of you said
anticipate
the needs that the needs of their units
be anticipated and provided for yeah
think about that word though
that the needs are anticipated that that
is a real word in there that is not
i'm here hey when you run out of stuff
come up and tell me hey and you run it
through the chain of command and give me
the
the triplicate paperwork to give you
what you need it's me knowing what's
going on down there and going hey jocko
you and the team have been getting after
it man how's your stash of
this supplier how's this going on here
are you running low because i can start
working this now to get this to you
and you're thinking damn he he didn't
just cut
us loose he's actually paying attention
what's going on down here and i was
about to send up
the request but i don't like asking my
boss for stuff so i was kind of worried
about asking him and he's thinking
i've noticed you guys have been cranking
do you need some of this
you're anticipating the needs not just
responding to their needs but actually
thinking about it
i mean you want to talk about being a
commander being a leader
knowing what your people are going
through and giving them what they need
before they have to ask for it
that word is no small word yeah and then
the
the parsing of that word
that you just used could clarify that
for everyone here
you said you need to actually think
about it
what does that mean that means while
you're daydreaming while you're sitting
around
uh doing whatever you're doing this
anticipation isn't just gonna come and
smack you in the face
you need to set aside a little time you
need to look at what that unit is doing
you need to figure out
you need to actually think about what's
going on
what a novel idea
that reminds me of way the warrior kid
where
the first one mark thinks he should know
his times tables
and uncle jake says we'll have you
studied and he says what do you mean
study no i should just know him
no and you're not going to be able to
just randomly anticipate people's needs
you need to actually think about it
and the last one in this chapter
oh sorry not the last one yet that
their successes be measured by the
overall ability of a unit to perform its
whole mission and not
by the performance of one or two factors
so look at
people holistically look at units
holistically and then this is the last
one
that good works by their units be
recognized and rewarded in such a way as
to motivate the greatest number to do
well
and seek further improvement good
now we're gonna roll into chapter two
this is called leadership versus
popularity
and this is this is interesting this is
where this is where i start to
uh sometimes when i'm reading leadership
things i'm like wait wow that's that's
really not my viewpoint hold on a second
like this is a little and then it and
then i continue to read and i find
oh he's saying it a little bit
differently but he
or he sometimes people are actually
saying something different but they
don't even mean it
they don't even mean it you're gonna see
what i'm talking about so leader versus
leadership versus popularity the example
of a strong leader
during the world war ii period i served
as a division commander
i served a division commander as his
chief of staff
and later as one of his combat
commanders for a period of over two
years
he was a strong character and a strong
leader he had firm ideas about things
that he liked and disliked
and placed requirements on his officers
and men in the fields of wearing
equipment and
uniforms tactical disposition during
field training
the care and handling of vehicles and
other things
many of which were unpopular at one time
in an evening discussion period i
pointed out that these requirements to
him
and asked him if he felt that the effort
he put
into them was not excessive for the
practical results which he achieved
his answer gave me insight into the
problems of training and preparations
and preparing troops for emergencies or
battle
for which i have never forgotten
he stated that in case of an emergency
or battle a commander
was required to place upon his officers
and men many requirements that were
unpopular and for which time was not
available for hesitation
the thought of being popular or
unpopular should never
enter the mind of a commander so that's
the part where i start going
wait a second what are we talking about
and i'm not totally there yet but i'm a
little bit nervous because he's
because what this translates to and leif
has talked about this before
leif had someone come and speak to the
junior officers a senior officer come
and talk to the junior officers
and and the message was in no uncertain
terms
hey when you're in charge you're you're
you should not be liked
you should not be liked when you're in
charge you're going to make all these
hard decisions people aren't going to
like you you need to be okay with that
and leif had to kind of like when this
senior officer would leave life kind of
had to like
back these guys down and say listen let
me put that in perspective yeah
so this is he pointed out that a
commander who was unable to attain
obtain compliance with unpopular
requirements from his officers or men
during training and during preparation
for combat
would not be able to obtain prompt
compliance
with his requirements to meet
emergencies or to attack an
enemy in battle he said that the
requirements he placed in the training
period served
three purposes one they conditioned his
com
command to carry out promptly his
instructions two
the way which his men carried out these
requirements served as
a constant measure to him of his hold
on his officers and his men and they
with other things helped instill a
fierce pride in the division
i might add that this officer was one of
the most respected division commanders
that i have known
even now over 15 years after he left the
division
he is the most popular man present when
the division association has
a convention so all this talk about him
not being concerned about me
this guy's the most popular guy he loves
him yeah everybody loves this guy
why do they love this guy do they love
him because he was nice do they love him
because he gave him extra brownies and
ice cream no he loved them because he
was dis
they loved him because he was
disciplined that's what they loved
later on when i was placed in command of
a combat command
of the division i remembered the
procedure off and i was
actually when i first read this thing i
was i thought he was talking about
patton
because he worked for patton but patton
wasn't alive 15 years later to be the
most popular guy
so i don't know who it was i have to do
more research
and this says an unpopular requirement
that paid off later on when i was placed
in command of a combat command
of the division i remembered the
procedure often used at leavenworth
of attacking at first light in the
morning one of the reasons for doing
this
was in hopes of catching the enemy
unprepared to resist attack
if we were taught this if we were taught
this probably the enemy did likewise
because of this whenever i had combat
command
in the field for training i required
every man to be up
dressed and manning his battle station
at first light
communications were checked all the way
from squad level to me
and reports of readiness were laid from
the squad level to me
after daylight and if it was decided
that no attack was probable
the troops were permitted to eat
breakfast and then proceed with the
day's activities
i talked about this one of the earliest
of podcasts
this early morning stand two that's what
it's called was never popular
and there would be many requests to
relax the requirement of it
particularly for men who had been on
guard or night duty while these requests
were never granted
because these requests were never
granted because i felt that if
that if we were overrun while still
asleep the enemy would not spare the man
who had been late getting into bed
boom
this procedure was followed in my
command throughout the war
i can say that even in the face of the
enemy it was not particularly popular so
even
even in combat guys were like bro let me
sleep in sir
let me sleep in even in combat even in
combat where the enemy might really
attack and kill you and overrun you
people
hey man can we just get some sleep in
the morning
but he never he never submitted
to that and he said however it did save
elements of my command on several
occasions from being overrun
and destroyed in the early morning at
one time a porsche a portion of the 37th
tank battalion
how cool is that the 13737
shout out to the bandits battle of
ramadi
a portion of the 37th tank battalion was
saved from destruction
by an enemy tank brigade attack in the
fog at first light because it was ready
this particular requirement was probably
most unpopular in my combat command
headquarters and there was considerable
griping about it on many occasions
however
one morning when my command was in the
rear of the enemy lines east
of nancy the headquarters personnel were
alert at first light
men were manning their defensive
positions weapons had been checked and
communications had been established
in particular the three tank destroyers
attached to my headquarters were in
position
loaded and manned at first light
a platoon of enemy tanks came into the
headquarters area
which in the case of a combat command
headquarters was not very large
the tank destroyers immediately took
them under fire and succeeded in
knocking out
three of the tanks the other two
withdrew
our loss during this engagement was only
one tank destroyer which was destroyed
by a direct hit from one of the enemy
tanks
there was much discussion of this attack
in the headquarters
in the days that followed one of the men
stated that he never realized how
crowded a combat command headquarters
could be when an enemy attack came
i heard no more comments in my
headquarters
about the requirement for everybody
being dressed alert in position in
daylight
the purpose of this account is to point
out that a commander
and leader owes a responsibility to his
men to require them to do things which
are
for their own benefit and for the
benefit of the command
as a whole even though the requirements
are not popular
so do you want to you want to follow a
thread
you want to follow a thread go read the
book about face and read what
what hackworth did when he took over the
439th
it's the it's the exact same story and
what he made these guys do
was change their you had to dig a hole
to sleep first of all
they they actually started digging in
they started moving their positions
every night they started expanding the
perimeter retract their perimeter and by
the way when you dig a hole
in vietnam or really anywhere when you
dig a fighting hole a fighting position
and then you're going to move
guess what you got to do with that one
that you just left you got to fill it in
so if if we put out the perimeter and
then we move back that night
25 or 50 meters because we don't want to
get mortared because we know the enemy
saw where we were
we got to fill in that fighting position
because we don't want the enemy to be
able to use it
so that's a lot of digging to be due to
be doing well guess what
he did this hackworth did this hey they
they got rid of all the crap that they
had in their in their battalion cp
they got rid of all that junk they
started digging in they started moving
their perimeter
and the first time they got mortared
under his command
there were no casualties because the
elements had moved and guess what there
was no more complaining
this is the exact same story i wonder
where hackword figured that out from
totally
next chapter ethics
conduct and standards of officers
subtitle set and example
what you know i had such a good benefit
my benefit that the
the luck that i had in my career in my
life is amazing
but one of the most amazing things is
when i was a young enlisted guy
in the seal teams i was watching my
lieutenant
i was tracking i was tracking those boys
when they forgot a piece of gear i was
like oh when they were late oh
i was tracking them and so i knew that i
knew
i knew better than anyone could have
ever taught me or told me like
we're sitting here saying this you've
said it five times today i've said it
eight times a day your people are
watching you
your people are watching you your people
are watching you i could have been told
that a hundred times and it wouldn't
have been as effective as me
actually knowing what it was like to
watch my my bosses
and note the good and note the bad
set an example the ethics conduct and
standards
of behavior of a few of our officers are
matters of real concern to me
except for a few junior officers our
officers are either regular
officers or reserve officers serving
because they chose to do so
it is up to the latter group to set the
proper example in
all things for those junior officers it
is up to all
officers to conduct themselves in such a
manner that the prestige of the
army officer will be high in the eyes of
the public
and of our enlisted men
an officer who behaves in an unbecoming
manner destroys his standing in a unit
man if we broke out and just started
talking about what's unbecoming for a
leader
you know when you hear the word conduct
unbecoming an officer you think like oh
this guy's out lacking like an idiot
what about when that guy shows up 12
minutes late
what about when that guy doesn't bring
the right piece of gear yeah what about
when that guy loses his temper well you
look whatever it is
all those little things all those little
things add up
and if you were a leader in an
organization you
got to understand that your people are
watching you
and what that actually is is an
opportunity to pull them into your
sphere of
influence because as a young marine
i was looking for role models too i was
looking when i was keeping track of
those little things
that little slip here that little slack
over here that little error here
and i was looking around when i saw the
ones that were that were holding the
line
that's where i wanted to be and if
you're that leader you will pull
these people into your sphere of
influence and you can lead and mentor
them and you can have
you can design the culture of the entire
unit by yourself just by setting that
right example
because you will pull people into your
sphere and they will follow that lead
and they will do the same thing
and then all of a sudden you got folks
down the organization that aren't
holding the line
you don't have to be the one to go down
there and fix it because you've got this
little army of people
on your little team that are doing that
across across the organization
uh so i was in the dames back in the day
and i was getting ready
i think i was actually i had been picked
up for the semen to admiral program
so i was i had been picked up
and i was super stoked and i was but i
was still at seal team one i had to
finish out my time there before i went
to officer candidate school
and then i would go from officer
candidate school so i either had been
picked up i think i'd been picked up
but another guy
another officer another prior enlisted
officer
who did the program that i wanted that i
was doing right
and he'd been picked up and he had gone
to officer candidate school
and then he showed up at seal team one
so he was you know he was
almost he was very similar to me in the
fact that we were both prying listen
guys he got picked up
i think it was one year ahead of me and
he shows up at seal team one
and i remember seeing this dude for the
first time
and look you you know i just looked at
him i was like
damn this dude is squared away
and i couldn't even really i couldn't
even really understand
i said why does this guy's whole uniform
look squared away this guy looks like
he's on another level
and you know we're in the locker room or
whatever well guess what
he was wearing shirt stays do you know
what those are i do
absolutely you do so he was wearing
shirt stays which is
the way that you roll with
at ocs it's like you're wearing shirt
stays that's all there is to it so for
those of you that don't know
what shirts days are they are a piece of
elastic material that
that you attach from the bottom of your
shirt which is tucked in
and they run down your legs and then
they attach to your socks
so no matter what happens your shirt is
freaking staying put and it looks like
um you look like it's it looks like the
uniform on a mannequin yeah
it looks like that somebody dressed this
thing for a mannequin
and so i i remember seeing it and going
damn this and he just look everything
looks squared away about him you know he
was in awesome physical shape
you know just a great guy and he he is a
an incredible
guy but i remember looking at him going
damn
this dude is squared away and i saw
those shirts i didn't know what those
were as an enlisted
seal you had no i had no idea showed up
at ocs
and you know what those shirts days
because
because pretty much when you're done
with ocs you don't really need to wear
them anymore
yeah guess what he did he did
and i did i freaking wore those things
religiously
because that's the difference that's the
difference
that's setting the example you better
look squared
hundred percent away the time all the
time where do you not want to look
squared away
and look if you got if you got long-term
plans and you want to build a team and
you got long-term plans of having a good
team around you
start early i remember joining my first
squadron
and and there's the training officer
bill it's called the training officer
it's like the junior
it's the senior of the junior officer so
it's that kind of the guy that's
elevated himself amongst all the junior
pilots
that's kind of in a key leadership role
and i remember
seeing a train and you see a squared
away trading officer like i want to be
like that guy and then that training
officer would go away and then a couple
years later he'd come back to a squadron
and he'd be the ops officer which is
like
a senior of the middle guys and he'd be
squared away by the time and i'm
this guy that that i worked with in my
squadron by the time that guy came back
to be a squadron commander who had been
squared away from day one
dudes were running down to headquarters
with cases of beer we like i want to get
in this guy's squadron people were
fighting to get into his unit was that
because he was nice
yeah was that because he gave people
extra liberty
because he was squared away and he held
the line and we all wanted to be like
him
and it's he didn't like wake up one day
like oh i'm a commander now i guess i
gotta square myself away he'd been like
that forever dudes were fighting to get
in his union
you know i was talking about leadership
capital the other day on ef online
because somebody asked a question about
it and one of the things
is your reputation can contain
a positive bank account of leadership
capital yeah
it can also contain a negative bank
account of leadership capital
and if you're not if you just decide
that you're going to get squared away
when you're put in charge if that's when
you make that decision
you're rolling in there with all kinds
of negative bank account
it's a disaster and with people you
don't even know your reputation extends
well beyond the people that you hang out
with oh for sure you know
in these communities people know you
have heard of you people are gonna run
towards you or avoid you
and you don't even know who they are and
it's gonna all be based on your
your account with them how much leader
leadership capital you've built
and it goes well beyond the sphere that
you think you're part of
everybody knows you in those leadership
roles and they're watching you
to the book the enlisted men have no
further respect for him
oh this is for the guy that that uh
behaves in conduct unbecoming of an
officer
the enlisted men have no further respect
for him and he can no longer lead or
command effectively
his value to his unit has largely been
destroyed when an officer accepts his
commission
he is presumed to have had enough
experience to have acquired the ethical
and moral precepts expected of an
officer and a gentleman
a record of long service is not an
excuse for laxity
in this matter damn he's coming off the
top roads right there
i just put myself in mental check for my
whole life
too often incidents are brought to my
attention
involving the intemperate use of alcohol
drunkenness at any time and place is
disgraceful
when combined with the operation of a
motor vehicle it becomes a potential
killer
drunk driving didn't used to be a thing
do you know that yeah oh yeah yeah
drunk driving didn't used to be a fail
it was a badge of honor back in the day
in some units
when my dad my dad crashed a car
drunk in like 1955 or something
and the cop like
pulled his car out and gave a ride home
i mean my dad was like
whatever 19 or something yeah and
and i got hit by a drunk driver when i
was a kid on a bicycle
and i got hit by a drunk driver i got
thrown off my bike i had
to get stitches in my head and
my dad was like oh yeah it was almost
like
it was almost like well you know you had
a little too much to drink
you know no factor the kid will be all
right can we get some money for a new
bike because the bike was trashed
yeah nowadays that would be game over
for that guy's whole life right
that'd be going a pr but would you go to
jail for that if you hit a kid on a bike
while you're drunk
i would say like no question you'd be
going to jail right
so it's pretty interesting that way back
then he's saying
when combined with the operation of a
motor vehicle becomes a potential killer
yeah he's
way out in front of the curve here this
is someone who's probably spent
way more time thinking about that type
of character than others because back
then
that wasn't a thing yeah you want to
know why he's probably
gone to visit all a bunch of guys in the
hospital that had drunk driving
accidents and repaired
you know had jeeps had to write off
jeeps and trucks and whatever else
these results are not only detrimental
to the individual but also to the
service particularly in overseas
commands commanders at all levels must
continually take aggressive action to
reduce excessive drinking and prevent
drunken driving
a long time ago again officers are
expected to set the example
the officers code army army regulations
provide that an officer's signature
is in itself a certification his
signature is his bond
a requirement is that an if an
officer is so to conduct himself that he
is deserving of such
trust appropriate administrative and
disciplinary action must be taken
against officers who are
guilty of misconduct and unwilling to
live within proper code
the officer an officer cannot expect to
retain his standing in prestige
as an officer where he was where he is
inefficient or
guilty of unbecoming conduct each
officer must clothe himself
with such a scale of values that he
knows instinctively the things
that an officer does not do
the officer's code does not get less
binding as he goes up in rank
the opposite is true it becomes more
binding
dude this dude is holding the line big
time i'm feeling like nervous
as i always have to point out i was a
young wild frog man
i did not come close to achieving these
standards
man
i would have loved to have read this
book when i was 18
19 20. i would have loved to have people
that were telling me
hey bro this is the path
this is it this is what you want to do
and you know what it takes to be able to
do that
here's the reality
for me to say hey you know what i made
mistakes and i do not want you to make
them
i want you to be better than me i want
you to be
better than i am i want your the
the end state of your life i want to be
superior to mine
that's what that's what drives giving
this kind of advice
hey listen i want the end state of your
life to be
superior to mine
that's what we should be thinking when
we interact with other people
we shouldn't have that little thing in
the back of our minds that's saying you
know what
i had to do this i had to learn the hard
way
i wish i would have done that but no one
told me to do that why should i tell him
what do you got just wrote it down
because that's a good one
that's that's leadership yeah
yeah crazy
i was recently invited to the us army
command
and general staff college to address the
faculty and students on the subject of
commandership and generalship following
my talk i was asked to comment
on the problem of integrity versus
professional loyalty
when an officer is confronted with
orders with which he has a strong
disagreement
i answered by citing two examples in my
experience once while a cadet
i asked a tactical officer a similar
question his answer was to carry out the
order loyally
and then when you are in in a tenable
position to recommend changes if
warranted
i followed this with good results so
there's your first answer
hey you know i asked dave to do
something that you don't agree with
what should you do well you should carry
it out and then you should pull me aside
when as soon as you get a chance to go
hey jonco this doesn't seem like it's a
good idea to me here's why
good got that
this is a longer example in another
instance when i was a commanding general
of the u.s continental army command we
were charged with the service testing of
an expensive and important piece of army
equipment
this was important enough to assign my
deputy a lieutenant general
to monitor closely the test went on for
several weeks one day my deputy reported
to me that the piece of equipment was
not
proving out satisfactorily he was fully
convinced
of his position i told him how serious
and how sensitive such a finding would
be
i directed that he called in several
officers closely concerned with the test
for a conference with me
this was done and all were unanimous
supporting the position of my deputy
they had data and results supporting
them so they're supposed to test this
piece of gear
there's a sounds like there's an
expected outcome it wasn't turning out
that way
i directed that they prepare a personal
letter for my signature
the chief of staff of the army or for my
signature for the
chief of staff of the army setting forth
their findings and conclusions
with supporting data and information
after approving and signing it
i had my aide deliver it by hand to the
chief of staff
within 48 hours i had a phone call from
the chief of staff he was disturbed
he told me how serious this was how
important the equipment was
and how not only the united states but
an allied power was
interested in it he wanted us to take a
positive approach and proceed with the
program
my reply so there you go he wrote out
hey there's the problems these are the
shortfalls this is what we all agree on
i'm letting you know and his boss says
hey
this is an interesting terminology
i want you i want you to take a positive
pres
positive approach and proceed take a
positive approach and proceed so
so i to me i translate that as hey lean
towards making this work
my reply was that i felt i owed him the
loyalty to bring the facts as i believe
them to his attention and having done
that i was prepared to
carry out fully his further instructions
the morals of this true story are the
chief of staff was in a position to now
this is important the chief of staff
was in a position to know of
considerations and factors of the higher
highest importance which i could not
know
now where i think this is if dave comes
to me and says hey i object to this or
i got this issue my response was like
hey dave here's what's going on man
here's why this is important here's
what's happening yeah i would tell you
why
here's some things you see that i don't
see here's some things you know i need
to know
yeah i had satisfied both my integrity
and professional loyalty as well as my
duty to my superior i was now free to
proceed without compromise
on my part to take a negative or i told
you so
attitude would not have been becoming to
a member of the team
all members of which were dedicated to
doing their best for the army and their
country
so i've i wrote about this in leadership
strategy and tactics
almost ad nauseam but there's so many
different ways to talk about it
and i even uh one that i i cite all the
time
is the band of brothers
dick winners totally yep you do the
recon someone gets killed the war is
literally within days of ending
you do a recon someone gets killed you
come back you get told to do another
recon the next night
and you say got it boss and then you go
have the guys drink wine in a cellar and
you don't do the recon
is that a good call yep
is it supporting the chain of command
nope um
did it protect the guys yes did it
accomplish a mission yes
could he have argued it a little bit and
i forget from the movie how they showed
it
i think he he pushed back he definitely
pushed back
but at a certain point pushing back
would have just gotten him fired and
then guess what
then they're going on the patrol then
they're going on the patrol with a yes
man with a yes ma'am yep
for sure and as you're building bill as
this story is building up there's a
there's a little part of me too but i
think of people listening like
so he's already done that he's going to
now hold the line
no sir i cannot in good conscience
put this in a positive light cool i'll
find somebody that can
and there's a part in there the humility
that it takes he's a
four-star general in this case to go you
know what
the chief of staff knows something i
don't know he sees something i don't see
can i consider that and try to go out
and go
hey i'll tell you what there are some
places over here this piece of equipment
actually does work pretty well
maybe not here and here but here's some
positive can i do that yeah it takes a
ton of humility
but if you don't do that the influence
you lose to actually provide the outcome
that you want
which is exactly what you're saying
think about the humility it takes
to go maybe i don't have the whole
picture
and this i'm gonna dig my heels and hold
the line because it's the right thing to
do
maybe i actually don't even know the
whole story cool you're fired right yep
see you later and i'll get a yes man in
there and he's gonna give me whatever i
want for report
and that's that yeah
so good
next section and this so this this is
chapter four prestige
of the non-commissioned officer and
again once again i sort of said well
maybe we don't need to cover this and
then as i read through it i realized
what this is talking about and this is
talking about something that i've
referred to quite a bit
on ef online lately so if you think
about it from this perspective
it starts to make a lot of sense way
beyond the military and that is
respect respect
so prestige of the non-commissioned
officer so if you think about this from
perspective of how do you respect people
and how important that is because that's
what he's talking about
continuing on advances in weapon systems
over the past few years have forced many
changes in our tactical organization and
operational concepts
the keynotes of our modern army are
mobility dispersion and sp small unit
operations this concept coupled with the
many new tools of war
requires greater reliance than ever
before on our non-commissioned officers
what are we talking about we're talking
about frontline leaders so if you're in
the civilian world we're talking about
frontline leaders
and guess what this guy was in world war
one and in world war one
there was not a bunch of reliance there
was not dispersion meaning everyone was
together you're in a big trench you're
all together when
it when the when the trumpet blows or
the whistle sounds or the
the signal comes we're all going at once
we're going to go over the top we're
going to charge
in with hundreds and hundreds of men at
the same time
there's no dispersion we're all close
together it's not small unit operations
and we're not moving so he saw that and
look he says mobility dispersion in
small unit operations what was world war
one
it was not mobile it was not dispersed
and it was not small unit operations
by the time he gets to korea and then he
gets to world war ii
or sorry world war ii and then korea
it's totally different and now he
realizes the importance of the front
line leaders
so how do we rely on these frontline
leaders so if you're thinking about your
frontline leaders
here's what you need to do fully develop
the non-commissioned officer to fulfill
this role a commander must place
responsibility on him
and permit him to assume his place in
command
you have to give them ownership in doing
this
standards of performance need not be
lowered
honest errors must be expected and
tolerated but corrected
senior personnel must not usurp
responsibilities which provide the
experience needed in developing
our junior leaders don't be the yes man
don't be the easy button sorry don't be
the easy butt
emphasis should be placed on the
non-commissioned officer's role
leader trainer supervisor
leader trainer supervisor this goes back
to the developing the
the echelon front certification program
think about this leader trainer
supervisor he's got them all mixed in
like we eventually got to yeah i didn't
even have this book when we were
starting to develop the program now that
i have it
i'm super stoked that we came to the
same conclusion and that is that a
leader
a trainer a supervisor a manager an
instructor
they're all qualities that are needed as
you come up the chain of command
if you're gonna be in charge of people
there follows a list of suggested
actions that may be taken
each by each commissioned officer at all
levels of command to further the
efficiency and enhance the stature of
the non-commissioned
officer corps again how do we respect
our frontline leaders
because the more respect we give them
the more respect they're going to give
us the more ownership we give them
the more ownership they're going to take
authority prevent the use of
non-commissioned officers for menial and
degrading tasks
okay ensure that
non-commissioned officers are
consistently addressed by their rank
so you're giving them that respect
adhere to the chain of command through
non-commissioned officer ranks right so
you don't
jump down to the front line and start
talking them without talking to that
frontline leader
reduce requirements for officer
supervision or mandatory presence at
troop formations let the
non-commissioned officer take charge
give them ownership
[Laughter]
sometimes for those of you that aren't
watching this on youtube when dave just
fully agrees with something he doesn't
nod his head yes he uh he
he shakes his head no as if to say this
is just no disputing this at all yeah
avoid mass withdrawal of
non-commissioned officer privileges but
take positive action against individual
concerns so don't do collective punitive
actions
when appropriate permit key
non-commissioned officers to attend
staff conferences
and commanders briefings hello
take that frontline leader bring them
into your your higher level meetings
let them see what's going on
ensure that deserving high quality
non-commissioned officers
are commended for outstanding
performance of duty by awarding them
combination ribbons letters of
appreciation or commendation
or certificates of achievement or and
this is jocko's edition
give them more responsibility give them
more ownership refrain from
over supervising the non-commissioned
officer after a task has been assigned
don't micromanage issue mission type
instructions
rather than detailed orders
once again i feel like i owe this guy
money i haven't said it i haven't said
that yet on this podcast but
when i read these things i feel like i
owe this guy money
whenever possible place senior
non-commissioned officers under the
supervision of commissioner warren
officers
inform non-commissioned officers in
advance of significant matters
pertaining to the units such as
maneuvers field problems training
requirements disciplinary
matters standards to avoid unfounded
rumors and allow for necessary advance
planning
at all echelons does it make sense that
you keep your unit informed
you keep your front line leaders
informed
what do you think they do when you don't
tell them what's happening do you think
they sit there and silently
uh wait await your word no they make
[__] up make it up yup
is there more this is ridiculous how
good this is
grant non-commissioned officers again
you can if you're listening this and
you're not in the military
just replace this with your front line
leaders grant frontline leaders
a greater voice in allowing privileges
or awards
awarding punishment consult with them
on matters involving the
reclassification and promotion of their
subordinates
let it be known that they greatly
influence these matters this is all this
whole thing is about giving away
responsibility and giving away ownership
use senior non-commissioned officers to
assist in conducting its inspections
ensure distribution of the directives to
non-commissioned officers so that they
may
have current information on military
matters
keep your keep your frontline leaders
informed
use senior non-commissioned officers as
instructors
back the actions of non-commissioned
officers publicly
to them as non-commissioned officers not
as ncos or non-comps which are two
slang terms which i do all the time ncos
non-coms
he's saying give them that and and look
it's a little slang term
give them that respect yeah and the
title is is the prestige of the ends of
the non-commissioned officer i mean
that's that
he's talking about it i mean that that
was just that was just a
recipe for leadership right there for
and like i said
these are your supervisors these are
your frontline supervisors whose
management is of the people
right at the point of friction the ones
doing the work
so these are your first line supervisors
and second line supervisors closest to
your people
out there making it happen and
if you want them to respect you you got
to give them respect
if you want them to trust you you have
to trust them and if you want them to
lead like you got to let them lead
and every single time you take
responsibility away from them he said in
the beginning you got to expect them to
make mistakes and make errors
you don't ignore it you correct it but
you don't take responsibility away from
them if i take
if you do something that's not what i
want you work for me you're one of my
supervisors you go out there and do
something it's not how i wanted it
and if i take that responsibility away
from you that's me telling you
i don't trust you and you know what the
return i'm gonna get that is
you don't trust me as much that means i
still gotta correct that i gotta show
hey jocko that's not what we're looking
for let me talk to you about what why we
did this and why let me explain these
things
but i get you right back out there to go
do it the reciprocal nature of the
relationship
everything you want from them you have
to give them
that it was literally a list it is a
checklist of leadership to get the
behavior
that you want you and i were on a call
with one of our clients the other day
and it was it was
one of those questions came up and
there's these four things
it's a call chrissy was on the call and
she was quite fired up she's awesome
absolutely but if you want people to
listen to you
listen to them if you want people to
respect them respect that if you want
people to respect you
you have to respect them if you want to
influence people you have to allow
them to influence you and if you want
people to trust you
you have to give them trust
a couple more things on this section
responsibilities insist on a thorough
appreciation of the non-commissioned
officer's full-time responsibility to
his men and to his commander
thorough appreciation
what does that mean that means respect a
point senior non-commissioned officer
counsels at each level of command
starting with the battalion separate so
again this idea of creating these
councils these groups within your
organization
so you can get good feedback is
brilliant
encourage non-commissioned officers
officer participation in civic affairs
great
the last section here is education and
training this is the last thing we're
going to cover
nothing can clothe with prestige
a non-commissioned officer who does not
know his job and does not play the part
expected of him
as a non-commissioned officer because of
that we should
one hold classes to ensure that
non-commissioned officers are
thoroughly trained for their jobs and
prepared to handle instructions
or duties when they appear before their
subordinates
what is that right there look i
am responsible for making sure that
people blow me in the chain of command
are ready to do their job totally
number two encourage attendance at
non-commissioned officers academy
and other courses designed to enhance
the prestige and set the standards
expected of non-commissioned officers
and three encourage non-commissioned
officers to take advantage of the many
opportunities to increase their general
level of education
and what's just amazing about this
this that's just another 13
pages of this document which is 117
pages long we made it through another i
think we
might have made it through 14 pages
but the section that closed it out is to
treat people with respect and
give them responsibility and train them
and educate them
to take care of your people now let's
point this out
i don't care how good of a leader you
are
if you don't invest in these subordinate
leaders so it doesn't matter what you do
because those those those
front line leaders are the ones that win
dude they're also the ones that lose
so invest in them treat them with
respect
listen to them allow them to influence
you
give them trust
and i don't care what your job is or
what your vocation is in life
you have to work with people and if you
work with people take care of those
people and those people are going to
take care of
you and
speaking of taking care of people
dave i know that you know that when the
aircraft
[Music]
cabin loses pressure the oxygen masks
drop down and you have to take care of
others of course but before you can take
care of others you got to take care of
yourself
to make sure that you have enough oxygen
to live so that you can then put the
oxygen mass on your children
so even though we need to take care of
others we need to take care of ourselves
first we got some ways of doing that one
of the ways is jocko fuel
which is supplements we got a bunch of
them we got joint warfare krill oil
we got discipline discipline go we got
disappointed with the cans are you on
number two right now
number two what flavors have you torn to
today dak savage
jacko palmer what's the preference that
doesn't actually count the one i had
earlier today
for my gig yeah so i guess i'm on number
three uh
we got vitamin d
d3 cold war look there's all kinds of
diseases out there
i'm not making any claims but some of us
haven't caught those diseases
so yeah check that out molk warrior kid
milk
adult milk which is just dessert we got
oh wait hey um we got a new flavor
coming
and it's so good
it says like allegedly we're doing it
seasonal but this thing ain't gonna be
seasonal this thing is gonna
all the time it's smashing pumpkin and i
don't even know
look i don't even know what um
i don't even know what pumpkin things
are supposed to taste like or whatever
but damn this thing is good it's so good
it's like a pumpkin
the original bee little sent me it was
he called you know the
generic name the flavor name it was
pumpkin spice
you know and so i'm i don't even know i
mean
you don't really eat pumpkin a lot right
i mean there's a pumpkin pie i get it
but you're not sitting around you know
going to the store grabbing a piece of
pumpkin and eating it that's not
happening
is that happening not not my house okay
negative so you're not even really 100
sure
what pumpkin flavor is
are you is anyone the only thing i can
think of is pumpkin pie
at thanksgiving maybe but to be honest
with you
so i don't even know what we're doing
but all i know is we created something
that's
freaking tasty it's got it's got like uh
i guess have you ever tried eggnog
before yeah it's sort of an
eggnog cinnamon scenario
sweet just monk fruit but it's so good
anyways we got that we got that going on
all this stuff we got giaco white tea uh
vitamin chop you can get all the stuff
at the vitamin shop also if you're
in florida right now you can get this
stuff at wawa
coming soon hopefully to all wawa's if
you're in florida
and you want to just kind of just
full-on support the cause great
here's a good way to support the cause
go in there and just clean them out
[Laughter]
go get your wawa on also you can get
this stuff at origin main.com what did i
miss did i miss anything nope
i'm on board with all that and i'll be
i'm actually excited about that new mulk
nobody has knocked strawberry off the
top of the platform that is still
remains
my go-to hey speaking of speaking of
discipline go
in the can of which you've had two three
three what flavor did you have earlier
today
uh i had uh oh i had a second giaco
palmer
this morning is that your kind of go-to
no i i look i'll be honest with you
i drink all of them i don't even look
for flavors anymore i reach in
the game dude i'm just in the game there
is not one that i can't
just be totally stoked to be drinking
now will there be one in the future that
you'll be more stoked to be drinking i
yeah i think there might be um so tell
us so let's go talk to us
after burner orange is coming out after
burner orange yeah
dave burke is getting his own
signature flavor
it's so crazy to think that i'm getting
my own signature flavor
of a product that i actually already
love
anyway but i'll be honest with you when
pete and brian at the team were like hey
bro we would love
to have you be part of this i
immediately went to my all-time favorite
soft drink
which i don't drink anymore which is
orange crush or orange soda whatever
that was back when we were kids
i don't drink it but i'll tell you it's
the best thing i've ever
i mean you're saying you don't drink it
anymore because you're just not going to
sit around drink sugar dude i don't
drink soda yeah i don't sit around
drinking oranges
but i you don't want to have conduct
unbecoming of an officer says yeah
sucking down sugar negative but
i would be lying if i didn't tell you
that i don't miss that flavor big time
so they were like hey what do you think
and it was immediate like bro
or i love orange and then the connection
afterward was so easy
because who thought of afterburner
orange
i think it was me i really do cool yeah
cool
and uh of course they designed it did
you have it going into the conversation
did you have it
well kind of like they had mentioned hey
i think the thing was like hey think
about it it'd be cool to do were there
any other name options that
got floated no just that was it it was
it was hey we you should do one
i thought about it i said hey what do
you think of this and pete was like done
we're executing yeah and then brian
executed and it happened and it was
totally good to go
do you know when the release date is i
think it's like in the next month
i think it's next month i think it's
even wait what month november so it's
coming out november i think so
afterburner orange yes
the dave burke signature
signature drink yeah and he's got a
plane on it what kind of plane did they
put on it
uh an f-35 silhouette oh dang did you
influence that
maybe and i might have made sure it was
the marine corps variant
oh damn layers in the business we call
those layers absolutely
dang yeah even though
when you were were you a charge when you
were a squadron commander was that a
marine corps squadron yes
that was a marine corps squadron with
the marine corps variant of the plane
what did you do with the air force
didn't you take over an air force
squadron at some point
air force division that was the f-22
raptor that was a straight-up air force
unit air force aircraft
i was a marine in an air force squadron
inside that squadron had a division of
all these different airplanes one was
the raptor division and that's where i
operated
dang yeah check all right so
we got all these cool drinks and they're
good for you they are which i know
which i know it doesn't make sense
because people don't understand how it
can happen i'll tell you how it can
happen
you don't cut corners you maintain
the the scrutiny on your product
to make sure that it's not junk
so like i said vitamin shop origin
maine.com you can get them
and wawa soon to be worldwide
uh also if you want jiu-jitsu gear so
jiu-jitsu gear
you're gonna need jiu-jitsu gear because
you want to train jiu-jitsu because it's
gonna free your mind
it is going to free your mind go to
origin main.com you can get
geez rash guards you can also get shorts
t-shirts joggers and guess what just
went back back into production
do you know dave i don't oh a little
something called delta genes
and i'll tell you what they're freaking
savage
i i said one time and pete like got a
big
what is it a chuckle out of this
which you can picture pete chuckling
right he's kind of a chuckler
he was chuckling when i said uh that
delta genes
are the greatest thing that i've ever
put on my legs
[Music]
[Laughter]
and um yeah so check out that we got
boots there
all that stuff's available it's all made
in america and that is what we're doing
we're bringing manufacturing back to
america
that is what we're doing go to origin
maine.com for that we also have another
store
which echo named jaco store
did echo name it that yes he did
actually he legitimately did
i guess so i was gonna take the hit on
the lack of creativity but i'm gonna
say echo is definitely involved in
making chocolate store dracostar.com we
got rash guards t-shirts
hats beanies all that kind of stuff we
got warrior kids soap there
so you can stay clean so check out
jocklestore.com
all this stuff will help support the
podcast as well
don't forget to subscribe to the podcast
leave a review
[Music]
i also have some other podcasts one's
called
unraveling jocko unraveling with daryl
cooper
another one's called the debrief podcast
which is still on this thread for now
but we talk about just pure leadership
it's a little shorter we try and make it
a little bit more concise because we
know leaders are out there working
you don't always have time for a three
hour podcast
grounded podcast warrior kid podcast we
have a youtube channel
where you can check out to see echo's
videos that he makes where he puts just
just
a ridiculous amount of fire and
explosions
he's not here to defend himself this is
boring
youtube channel psychological warfare
album tracks mp3 flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer making cool stuff to hang
on your wall
got a bunch of books about face the
thread that leads to this book that
we're talking about today about face i
wrote the forward to the newest version
you can check that out also the code the
evaluation the protocol written by dave
burke
and me and sarah armstrong
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the answer to all the questions
the answer to all the questions yeah
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual
way the warrior kid one two and three
way of the warrior kid four field manual
available for pre-order right now hey
guess what
i used to make fun of my publisher
and say they they're they're they're
scared about ordering too many books
they don't know how many books to order
i'm telling them
if you pre-order this it lets me know
how many books to order
because this is hard to sit on
a bunch of books i want to produce the
amount that are needed i don't want
anyone to get
christmas to come and you got no way the
warrior kid four
field manual so
pre-order that if you want mike in the
dragons get some of that dismantles
freedom field manual brand new versions
out
got a bigger picture of my head on the
cover like oh you wanna oh we
to make it we want to make a new version
we want it to be better oh what should
we do
make the picture of my head bigger is
that supposed to make it better on what
they're thinking
also extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership
the og books
check those out echelon front it's our
leadership consultancy we
solve problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com
hey if you want me or life or dave
or jp or anyone on the echelon front
team to come and talk to your company
don't google jocko speaker
go to ashlandfront.com if you google
jocko speaker there's going to be people
that
are paying google words to get you to
click on their thing and they're gonna
be a middleman you don't need them go to
ashlandfront.com
if you want to get some other training
for leadership go to efonline.com
this is what we do we teach leadership
there's courses on there we're doing
live q as
all the time there's a forum there's
other people to interact with there's
leadership primers there's immediate
action drills
there's questions there's all kinds of
stuff and if you're in a leadership
position go there and guess what you're
in a leadership position if you
interact with other human beings you're
in a leadership position
what else on ef online dave do we're
there live all the time
we were there yesterday we're there
tomorrow and you don't even know what
day
it is that you're listening to this
podcast because it's either going to be
today or tomorrow you can talk to us
directly live so come join us for
awesome what if someone has a question
for dave burke what should they do
they should come to if online live and
ask me that question what if they have a
question for
jp to know what should they do the same
thing what if they have a question for
me what if they say well you know i
twittered
i sent nine tweets to jocko but he
didn't answer because he has
80 million tweets what should i do
same thing go to if online it's awesome
go to efonline.com
we have a live event muster 2020
is the only one we're doing in 2020 we
have
we have this is not the first live event
we're doing we've done other live events
i know you've done some live events i
know i've done live events
look there's social distance you can
maintain the social distance
we'll have the appropriate measures in
place
so you can come to the muster it will be
fully engaged look
one thing that's kind of cool at the
muster at the
at the previous musters before kovid
there's a thousand people there there's
800 people there
there's 900 people there so that means
900 people
trying to talk to us during the breaks
whatever there's no green room if you've
never heard there's no green room we're
there we're talking
so if you want to hang out with us if
you want to get some information
directly from us
come to the muster there's probably
going to be a fraction
well i would say there's gonna be less
than half probably less than 500 people
at the muster
and and believe me you spread that out
over a couple days you're gonna
talk to us ask the questions we'll do
whatever we need to do to make sure that
you come away from that with the
knowledge that you need
so go to extremeownership.com for
details there
of course we have ef overwatch if you
need
leadership in your team which you do we
have
we are selecting leaders
from the military that understand the
principles we talk about all the time
and we're placing them into
civilian companies into your business go
to eforewatch.com
if you need leaders in your company if
you want to help
service members active and retired if
you want to help their families if you
want to help gold star families around
the world
then check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved then
go to americasmightywarriors.org
and if you look if you just are
constantly seeking that hard path
and you want to do things that are tough
do things that cause you a little bit of
suffering
then maybe you want more of my guttural
groans as i talk
or maybe you want more of dave's
frothing phonetics
well either way you can find us on the
interwebs
on twitter on instagram and on facebook
dave is at
david r burke and i am at jaco willink
and thanks once again to general bruce
clark
for your service to america and for
leaving these lessons of leadership
behind
for us and thanks to all those people
in uniform out there right now that are
utilizing
these lessons to protect freedom in the
world
and to police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service all other first
responders
thank you for protecting us from chaos
and mayhem
here at home and everyone else
remember these lessons from general
clark
remember the importance of time that's
where we started this whole thing today
don't forget about that one remember the
importance of time the clock is ticking
try and anticipate problems be reliable
be knowledgeable show initiative
and when you cast judgment which i do i
read these books and i think oh that
person
i wish that person would do that and i
wish that person would do the other
thing
and then i remember that when you cast
judgment
start off by judging yourself
because it all starts with you
and until next time this is dave
and jocko out